>>
Please help me in welcoming Ben Huh to Google.
>> [Clapping]
Ben Huh: Thanks, everybody, for being here
today.
I really appreciate it.
It's really nice to come and talk to Google
like this, because you guys impact so much
of our lives -- especially the way we actually
communicate the things that we find funny.
I'm sure a lot of lolcats have passed through
the pipes of Google over the last couple years.
So I'm here to talk about what I call "microhumor."
And this is the part of humor that gets largely
ignored by mass media.
And I think, in order to understand microhumor,
I'll start by explaining the other humor that
we are normally used to.
And, by the way, that's my Twitter name.
If you want to tweet this and tell me what
you think, I'd be more than happy to read
that and include your feedback in my next
presentation.
So, I'm going to start with a magic quadrant.
So we've got 'Reach' -- which is mass reach,
or private.
So basically, it's a meaning of exposure -- how
many people know about this specific subject
item.
And then, we go to 'Acceptance', which is
-- Some things are not really funny for a
lot of people, and some things are funny to
a lot of people, whether they know it or not.
And I call it the "I agree it's lol" axis.
And when you put the two together, you get
a quadrant like this.
You've got "Ooh, that's awkward."
You've got the "Mass Stardom".
You've got "Microhumor", which is what I'm
here to talk about today mostly.
And then, you have the, "Dude, you have to
see this."
Unfortunately, the two -- upper-left and lower-right
-- I really don't have a great name for it.
So that's why they're a little bit longer
than the other two.
So, I'm actually going to overlay, over this
magic quadrant, the humor and the type of
content that we're used to.
So this slide might take a little bit to read.
[pause] So, you've got Ben Stiller movies,
which I think they've become more moved to
the right ever since he did "Tropic Thunder",
right?
And then, you've got like racist jokes and
sexist jokes that like, most people don't
agree are funny, but maybe they think it's
funny in private.
But everybody knows that it exists, right?
And you've got the inside joke, which is on
the bottom left hand corner -- the jokes that
we only tell our friends.
This is the type of content that a lot of
us are actually getting really used to today
-- through Twitter, through e-mails, through
IM'ing, where we're sharing a little bit of
our lives.
And this is like the stuff that's overheard,
or maybe the Quote Board in its form, back
in the day.
You know, if you remember those things from
your dorm life, this is where it all starts,
right? -- the inside joke.
So I'm going to take an example of puns, which
is a type of humor format we're very familiar
with.
And puns can range from, "Ooh, that's really
awkward.
Like, that's really not that funny, but I
know that that's a pun."
All the way to, you know, there are some really
great puns out there.
Like, actually I can't really think of one
right now.
But most of the like, you know, hair salon,
and the pet news headline puns kind of fall
under the, "Ooh, that's awkward," category,
right?
We've seen them all like, what is it?
Great clips. Oh, I get it -- you clip my hair.
Ha ha, right?
So, I'm going to take this quadrant and analyze
a mean that we're very familiar with.
[laughter] I've saved you the trouble of actually
not playing this video.
So I will not actually Rickroll you.
That's the best applause I've gotten all year.
So, I'm going to talk about how Rickrolling
started, right?
It started as Duckrolling, which was on 4chan
boards.
They used to post a picture of a duck and
you click a link and like, "Oh, I got Duckrolled,
right?"
So it's a very private thing.
A lot of people on 4chan found it funny.
But it moved, right?
It moved when it became Rickrolling.
It was still private, but most people Rick
Astley's far funnier than a wooden duck.
Go figure, right?
So it moved to Rickrolling, right?
So this is a mean as it grows and evolves.
And then, it hit a mass and consensus, which
was when YouTube decided on April 1st, 2008,
to Rickroll everybody, by changing their links
on the home page.
Like, this was the total, you know, peak of
this mean.
And then afterwards -- after April first -- after
everybody had seen it, it kind of died off,
and said, "Okay, I've been Rickrolled sixteen
times in a day.
You know, how many more times can I take the
same joke?"
So it actually moved from one quadrant all
the way to all four.
And let me tell you why it moves.
It moves from one quadrant to another, this
little humor that was inside joke within 4chan,
I always distract my own audience by posting
lolcats.
It moved, because it's evolutionary, right?
It was a Duckroll, which wasn't as funny as
Rick Astley.
And then, people thought, "You know, being
able to prank somebody by making a link go
to a different place that we all assume is
one thing then appears to be something really
ridiculous, it's a part of collective truism.
Meaning, we actually understand this to be
true internally, whether we had witnessed
this previously or not.
Timeliness -- April 1st, right?
April Fool's Day.
What a great day to do a joke.
So, as the mean grew, it hit this peak, because,
"Hey, everybody needed a prank, right?
April 1st."
So YouTube picked this thing and made it huge.
And marketing -- because YouTube is so giant,
in terms of the world of videos, it had the
biggest platform available for this mean to
go viral.
And you can literally see that on Google Trends.
So in 2007 -- this is Google Trends of people
Googling for the word 'Rickrolling'.
So it started as Duckrolling.
Nobody was looking for 'Duckrolling'.
Nobody cared; it was a private joke.
When it moved to another quadrant as more
and more people discovered it, people were
trying to find out what Rickrolling was, and
they were Googling it.
April Fool's, it peaked.
Everybody, who previously wasn't aware of
Rickrolling, now knew exactly what it was
-- thanks to YouTube.
And then, afterwards, you can see, it died
down.
It ended up at a slightly higher peak than
before, but it's actually drifted off even
more so since then.
So you can see how this internal mean humor
went viral literally by looking at Google
Trends.
Well, so let's go back and define microhumor,
where this thing came from.
And I'm going to overanalyze.
I love this one.
This was actually one of the very first photos
I posted on the FAIL blog.
The expression on her face is just priceless
if you can see that.
And then, the fact that the frisbee was within
arm's reach, just outside.
It just makes this perfect.
So this was an inside joke.
A guy, who was taking photos of a frisbee
match, decided that he wanted to send this
photo around to his friends.
And his friends decided that this was so funny
that, they suggest that he send it to FAIL
blog.
And we posted it.
Well, prior to invention of a FAIL blog -- and
other things like it -- this would have been
just an inside joke, "Ha ha, whatever her
name is fell on her face. Face plant. That's
really funny."
Well, this is exactly where all Internet means
start.
This little subculture -- this little subgroup
-- who find something to be compelling enough
to share with other people.
Unless you can actually overcome the resistance
within that small subculture, where they all
agree that this is worth sharing, the mean
never makes it out of that group.
So what usually happens is, when you guys
have an inside joke, right?
A very good example of an inside joke that
made it out is, what is it?
"That's what she said," right?
Or "your mama." That's pretty bad.
But, you know, "That's what she said" can
be applied to a lot of different things.
It's a mean.
Whether we know it as an Internet mean or
not, we tend to use the word 'mean' according
to the Internet, but that went from person
to person practically overnight.
Like, I don't know exactly what started -- and
usually with means, you can't really pinpoint
the beginning of it.
But "That's what she said" became an idea
that everybody kind of learned without explicitly
learning it.
So, let's describe what is microhumor and
what is not.
It isn't web two point whatever.
It isn't new. It isn't really a mean.
It isn't Internet-based.
And it is not the root of all humor.
What it is, is that, it's the first exposure
to humor we've had as kids, right?
When you guys were talking with your other,
you know, third-grade friends and somebody
said something funny and it was because the
context of being a third grader in your little
sandpit, you know, somebody did something
funny, but you didn't recognize that as a
mass-media thing.
You laughed and you forgot about it and you
moved on.
It's most of why we laugh.
The fact that I'm here today talking to you
about Internet means is relevant to this subculture,
or this subgroup of people, right?
We're pretty much a very small community in
the grand scheme of the world.
Not a lot of people work for the biggest technology
company in the world, right?
Not a lot of people spend most of their lives
on the Internet, like I do, right?
We share very much a commonality that we appreciate
Internet culture for what it is -- something
that's funny to us.
And it is more intimate.
And this is one of the reasons why microhumor
tends to make it out, when it's really good,
because we feel somewhat of an ownership of
it.
We feel passionate about that little joke,
and we want to share it with the rest of the
world.
So, before mass media, microhumor was the
Force, right?
Maybe it was the Dark Side, maybe it wasn't.
But this was the thing that we were all used
to.
Like, in the Middle Ages, the Court -- the
King's Court, the Queen's Court -- had a jester.
And the jester would make fun of other, you
know, members of the royal family, or maybe
he or she got beheaded for that.
But you know, maybe like other things that
the king knew about, they wanted to share
this thing called microhumor -- things that
were contextually relevant and funny to that
group of people.
However, things changed when mass media came
into view, right?
So if you look at the potential economic value
of different types of humor.
When TV came into view.
The big, upper right quadrant -- meaning things
that's funny to a lot of people -- got the
money, right?
The balance completely became out of whack.
Whereas before, in the age before mass media,
the inside joke was the only thing that held
sway, because we didn't have the ability to
communicate with other people and share this
joke.
So the balance went from microhumor all the
way to, you know, the stardom part, and nothing
in between.
Well, the Internet is changing that, as you
can clearly see and experience, right?
I'm going to let you laugh at this first.
[laughter]
This would never make it on television. [laughter]
It just doesn't work.
But we find it really funny.
What we're doing is, we're refragmenting humor
in mass media, mass culture.
More people can find more things funny.
Our tastes have become broader.
Our tastes have become more eccentric almost.
And we're taking the power away from mass
media -- such as television and radio -- into
our own hands, because we can go and find
and share and filter the things that we find
funny that maybe other people don't.
It's because we can now publish things easily,
because we can access and find things.
We can find other people who share the same
sense of humor.
And there's a feedback group that says, "Hey,
that was funny.
I think this is funnier."
That's why means work, because it requires
a two-directional effort in trying to make
something evolve to the next level.
So we're growing -- these nuts -- right?
These crazy Internet people with their weird
sense of humor of captioning cat photos with
misspelled words.
Where the hell do they come from?
TV got, you know, kind of blind-sided by this.
Or mass media got blind-sided.
That's why they're so interested in this story
called lolcats and FAIL blog and Graph Jam,
because well, who the heck liked this stuff
before TV was around?
Well, we probably did, but there was no way
to access it.
There was no way to share the fact that we
liked it.
And if you look at this ridiculous slide of
people, right?
Evolution of dance, Chuck Norris.
I mean talk about a mean.
Chuck Norris, who practically is a has-been
on television, got a second wind, thanks to
Chuck Norris "facts," right?
These ridiculous sayings about what Chuck
Norris could do.
He can count to infinity twice.
I mean, it's like -- [laughter] You know,
it's ridiculous, right?
Like behind his beard is a fist.
[laughter] Dr. Horrible Sing-Along Blog.
Has anybody seen that one?
Oh yeah, see?
Okay, I'm talking to the right audience, right?
That was created, because the TV writers went
on strike.
And they had free time, and they wanted to
create a drama that they enjoyed.
It's really quirky.
It features Dudy Hauser, right?
I mean what an awesome guy, right?
And that never would have been made, if it
wasn't for the Internet.
It was released online.
iTunes picked it up.
We all saw it, because it wasn't on TV.
We saw it online.
And we probably told our friends about it.
There was no marketing budget.
Taze All Day, [singing] Chocolate Rain.
Yeah, that's pretty inside there.
This is a case where a very not-talented person
got on the Internet, decided that he wanted
to be talented and made an absolutely ridiculous
song called "Chocolate Rain," which I don't
even want to think about.
So, and he ended up in a Dr. Pepper commercial,
right?
So this is a case where, again, some subgroup
of people decided that this was so ridiculous
that they wanted to share it with other people.
I won't go through everything, but as you
can see, things like this is how it all starts.
So this is actually not the oldest lolcat
by the way.
This is a poster from the 70's.
The oldest lolcat that we found -- and I wish
I would have brought the picture with me.
It was printed, as far as I can tell, 1904.
And I'm not kidding.
Somebody who went to an antique store in Seattle,
found this postcard of a kitten sitting in
a highchair dressed up like a little girl,
and there's an all-caps caption underneath
the photo that said, "Mommy, where's my dinner?"
If it had made an impact, like done! That's
a lolcat, right?
It wasn't even a predecessor.
That would have been an actual lolcat.
And this was because -- this was the beginning
days of photography.
They wanted to, I guess, make postcards that
other people bought.
So the idea of captioning a cat is not new.
I'm pretty sure if you go to Egypt, somewhere
in the pyramids, [laughter] there's a cat
with a caption underneath it.
"Mommy, can I have a Sycophagus?"
I don't know. [laughter]
So, I'm going to go back and talk a little
bit about how we all got started.
So Eric and Kerry, the cofounders of I Can
Has Cheezburger actually came here and talked
to you guys about a year ago about the founding
of I Can Has Cheezburger.
And they can tell you about how it just went
from having a blog that had a couple of pictures
of lolcats to this massive, you know, Internet
phenomenon practically overnight.
I showed up sometime in April, as the site
was taking off.
And the first time I saw it, I didn't get
it.
Second time somebody sent me a link, I didn't
get it.
By the third time, I said, "Jeez, I'm not
going to go there again," but I did.
And then, I found something I liked.
Something that appealed to my sense of humor.
And then, I sent it to my friends.
I said, "Dude, you got to check this out."
Right?
That's like microhumor in action.
It appealed -- some context of that joke appealed
to me.
I wish I could remember which one that was.
And I said, "I have to share it with my friends
who share my sense of humor."
And the site continued to grow.
And in September, that's when I took over,
we knew absolutely nothing about how to run
this blog. [laughter]
That's exactly how I felt.
What is this blog?
How do you get these pictures?
So, in September, we realize that -- just
like microhumor -- the good solutions are
the really simple solutions.
So we focused on just making sure that you
guys got the lolcats that you wanted.
And we started growing like crazy.
So that's millions of pays to the left by
the way.
And we were profitable from day one, which
was the other crazy part.
So when I raised investment money to purchase
I Can Has Cheezburger on these little blogs,
you know, the investor said, "Well, how much
am I going to have to put in, because can
you make money off this?"
And I said, "Yeah, we can actually make money."
That was kind of the watershed moment, when
we had our first month's worth of revenues
come in, and said, "Oh, my God, we actually
didn't lose anything."
And we kept on growing, which is very contradictory
to what people believe about how new media
works. [laughter]
Yeah, this one takes a few seconds, so.
We were a blog, posting weird cat photos and
turning a profit, whereas other people doing
great work, creating great content, weren't.
And there's something weird about that.
And we kept on growing.
And we added more blogs.
I'm sure you know about FAIL blog and Graph
Jam.
FAIL blog we actually acquired from a guy
in London in April of 2008.
And I think that's the last big acquisition
that we're going to do, because the world
has really changed since we started doing
this.
We've created this kind of cottage industry
of people who post pictures online and try
to make a living off it, which is bizarre,
because in two years, that is a really, really
fast turn around.
Before we were really in existence, no one
knew that you could actually make a living
doing this.
And now, there's a bunch of people who like,
have a part-time job at home, posting pictures
of whatever it is they find funny.
And the odds of them actually making money
are very slim, but so is becoming a Hollywood
star, and people try anyway, right?
It's this idea that you can affect the world
with your sense of humor that seems to be
virally infectious to other people.
And I have no idea why I included this slide.
[laughter]
Rest in peace, Michael Jackson/dude from Egypt.
So, we found the same idea to be true, that
we could go out and buy blogs if we wanted
to.
But we could also build our own, like "Totally
Looks Like."
This idea was inspired by -- you guys remember
Mad Magazine?
They used to have a feature called "Separate
at Birth," I think, which would feature like,
two celebrities.
That's where this came from.
All we did was, we just made a place online
where you can submit your own.
And then, "Totally Looks Like" was born.
So, as we added our blogs, we kept on growing
and growing and growing.
So that's August 2008.
And I'll also share with you our planning
philosophy.
And we said, "You know, what we're doing is
working so well."
It's a little hard to read, but this is a
song. [laughter]
Got some music. You just got it?
Okay. It takes a while. But anyway.
That's what Graph Jam is all about.
But we decided that 30 days of planning was
just enough.
That we did not have to plan out years in
advance, because let's face it, we're a cat
blog.
And when you are a cat blog, you just want
to live till tomorrow.
And this has worked really well for us, just
focusing on what we do well, posting other
people's content that are funny according
to other people's standards.
Because if you go to our site, you'll realize
everything is voted upon.
Like, we don't sit there and go, "We think
this is funny."
We let the users decide.
So not only do we crowd source our material,
we crowd filter the best of the best.
So people started calling us a "user-generated,
content pioneer," which is a very nice label.
Which is like saying, well, the earth would
be mass media, and user-generated content
would be the sun, because we create so much
content.
You know, Blogger?
My God, there's so much content on Blogger,
right?
So basically what "UGC pioneer" means, people
crazy enough to go sift through all this stuff
out there, right?
That's all we're doing is trying to figure
out how to take the best of what people are
creating and send it and show it to the right
audience.
And this is our traffic growth.
This is for until last month.
We exceeded 200 million page views.
And now, we're on pace to do a billion pages
every four months.
And, oddly enough, we now have the number
sixth all-time watched channel on YouTube
thanks to FAIL blog.
So FAIL blog's videos came in about sixteen
months ago, eighteen months ago.
Somebody sent us a video and said, "You should
post this on FAIL blog."
And I said, "We don't post videos on FAIL
blog. This is a photo blog, dammit!"
Well, we posted it anyway, because I got overruled,
and it grew and it grew and it grew.
And we just passed CBS as the sixth most-watched
channel on YouTube of all time in 18 months.
I mean, that's just crazy, right?
It's just videos of people failing. [laughter]
Sometimes videos of professionals failing,
but it's not rocket science.
It really isn't.
And a lot of these videos had been seen by
other people before, and what we did was,
we used crowd sourcing to put that in front
of a wide audience and to allow them to decide
what they believed was good.
That's all it was.
Also, the financial crisis helped, which then
the word 'fail' came [undecipherable]
So, let's think about this.
April 2008, I buy the blog, it starts growing.
September of 2008, the financial crisis happened,
and banks fail.
And there's a photo of some person at a Senate
hearing of the banks.
And she is holding a sign that says, "Fail."
[laughter]
I remember looking at that picture going,
"I better buy some more servers."
[laughter] And that was it.
And that's our story so far.
We keep launching a new blog every week.
I'm trying to test out what is funny and what
isn't.
The latest blog that we launched is a little,
cute, baby product blog.
So we basically -- you know, I was talking
to Molly Wood, who's the executive editor
at CNET.
And she was basically telling me, "You guys
basically live in the world of extreme, making
fun of other people's failures or really cute
stuff."
And I'm like, "Oh, I didn't really know that."
"Like you guys," she said, "were basically
doing two extremes of happiness -- watching
other people's misery, or watching cute things."
I'm like, "That's really good. Thanks.
I'm actually going to go back to the office
and tell them about this."
And this is the best part about my job is
that I comment and meet with other people
who visit our blogs and they tell us what
to do.
Our mission statement is "To make people happy
for five minutes a day."
And it's not some kind of wisdom I crafted
from my little, windowless office.
It was actually something that was sent in
to us by our users.
They kept on e-mailing us, and they said,
"Hey, guys.
We love your blog, because it's my five-minute
break from the office."
Or "I print out lolcats, and I take it to
my grandmother who's recovering from cancer,
and we share a laugh over it.
She has no idea that there's this stuff on
the Internet."
You know? And that was really great.
And we adopted that as our mission statement.
Because, for us, the microhumor -- the little
joys we share with other people -- is what
we specialize in.
And if we can continue to make more blogs
that make people laugh for just a few minutes,
then we've won.
So that's it. That's me.
If you have any questions, feel free to send
me an e-mail, and I'd love to take your questions.
>> [Clapping]
>> So if anyone has any questions, they can
go ahead and come up to the microphone.
It'll be right here.
Go ahead and ask a question.
Ben Huh: Don't feel too shy.
>> Or I can come to you if you have a question,
if you prefer.
Ben Huh: I'm going to find some photos to
show you guys.
I think this was a crowd favorite.
Somebody post that one.
There you go, that's how I roll.
I'm not sure how the cat got in there, but
I'm pretty sure you can't force a cat into
a tube like that.
Q Question from San Francisco.
Do you know what your all-time, most-visited
photo is?
Ben Huh: Our all-time, most-visited photo
varies.
Because, as we grow, the photos that we post
at a later date tend to get the most views.
So that's kind of a tricky question.
So people have asked us, "Can you guys do
a Best Of?"
I'm like, "How do we decide that? I don't
know, right?"
Because, as traffic grows, the stuff we post
on the home page become more and more -- seen
by more people.
So, I wish I knew that, actually.
That would be great.
Q So would that be a cat roll?
Ben Huh: That would be a cat roll.
There's also a subway cat, which is a similar
cat, but in -- cat is by itself, and then,
it says 'Catway'.
I'm not sure why that says 'Catway,' but it
does.
Q It's great to have you here.
FAIL blog has worked its way into a meditative
process that I have every night before I go
to bed. [laughter]
I log into it and I start laughing, because
I used to look at the New York Times, and
it just got so depressing.
I'll be rolling -- literally rolling -- on
the floor, laughing, reading the thing.
And when my ex was living with me.
She just never got it.
Ben Huh: Is that why she's your ex? [laughter]
Q Yeah, exactly. Exactly.
Ben Huh: I'm great to have contributed to
the breakup of relationships.
Q I won't go into that here.
But I mean, maybe you could talk a little
bit more about the thing you touched on in
the mean like, people kind of get it.
And people who don't.
Because I think not everybody gets it.
Ben Huh: That's the interesting part about
what we do is that we're serving up humor
in a very fragmented community.
Not everybody gets FAIL blog.
Not everybody gets I Can Has Cheezburger.
Not everybody gets Graph Jam.
But that's okay with me.
People say, "Well, this is not funny."
I'm like, "That's okay.
Other people find it funny, and that's really
who we're targeting."
So that's why we've got 28 blogs now.
And we've gone from one cat blog to a network
of 28-plus blogs, where we try out new material
every week.
It's like being a stand-up comedian.
If it doesn't work, we won't use it again.
So, we launched "There, I Fixed It," which
was leftover content from FAIL blog.
People would send us -- "There I Fixed It"
is a site that features horrible fix-up jobs.
So like, that shower curtain that's actually
not attached by rings -- but with like, duct
tape -- to the rod.
So you have to basically climb under the curtain
to get in there.
There's a ladder that's been apparently -- a
ladder that's replaced a staircase, and if
you look closely, the ladder is actually bolted
into the wall, because it's been there so
long.
And it's actually a ladder on top of a ladder,
which makes me wonder if that house owner
is still alive.
So, it's stuff like this that was sent to
the FAIL blog.
We're like, "You know, this really isn't a
fail, because there's nobody actually falling
off of it right now, but maybe we could start
something else." So we started, "There, I
Fixed It."
So, it's things like this, where subcultures
give us an idea into what they would like
to see, and that's what we try.
Yeah.
Q Just wondering.
I guess before lolcats came along, we had
like all these really big forums of something
awful like -- I remember the days of the old
really owl, which I love.
Ben Huh: Yeah.
Q And I was just wondering like, How -- have
you thought about that fact or how that in
a sense kind of maybe grew into this sensation?
Or?
Ben Huh: Actually, that's where it all came
from.
So, lolcats -- as a phenomenon -- came from
4chan, which made its way out to "something
awful" "for a phase" all of those forums I'm
sure you're aware of.
And then, from there, it made a crossover
into kind of mass blogging world.
And that's where I Can Has Cheezburger first
started.
So lolcats was an invention of a very sick
group of people.
Also very creative group of people, right?
FAIL -- it didn't really come from 4chan.
Graph Jam came from a community on Flicker.
So all these ideas germinate from somewhere
else.
And even then, if you think about it, those
ideas germinated from a different era.
So there was a woman named Jessica Hagee,
who's got a book that's really a bunch of
graphs that she draws.
Veni Tree Martin is a comedian who draws graphs
as part of his comedy routine, and that's
what was the inspiration for that.
And I'm sure they will tell you they were
inspired by something else.
So, the idea of a mean actually having a starting
point is really hard to pinpoint.
But yeah, those forums were a very big, influential
group, because they created a lot of the content
that we know as the early lolcats today, so.
Yeah. Any other questions?
Q Question from San Francisco.
Ben Huh: Yeah.
Q Thanks for coming, by the way.
I really appreciate almost all of your blogs,
so.
Thank you for wasting hours and hours and
hours of my time in the best way.
So now, you were just talking about Graph
Jam -- and maybe I missed it, but that's the
only one that's really your content, right?
You guys are actually -- that's not user-submitted;
is it?
Ben Huh: Graph Jam.
I think, if I heard your question correctly,
the question is, Is Graph Jam user-submitted?
Q Right.
Ben Huh: Yeah, it's all user-submitted.
If you go to Graph Jam, there's a graph-builder/uploader,
and you can go make your own graphs.
What was really fascinating -- it's a little
flash builder, which allows you to make graphs
without actually punching in numbers.
If you kind of think about that, that's really
crazy, right?
Graphs without the use of numbers.
You can draw a pie chart just by dragging
a line and going, "Ooh, look I think it's
about this much percent." [Laughter]
Well, that's what we found out.
So we see all the submissions that come in
through our system, because the moderator
looks at this stuff.
And then, we started seeing actual, corporate,
company data.
Like somebody decided Excel was too hard and
decided that they wanted to make a financial
presentation out of using Graph Jam's graph-builder.
[laughter]
Unfortunately, I do not know the name of this
company, because I would go short their stock
tomorrow.
But yeah, people do this actually quite frequently,
and it scares the bejesus out of me, because
I'm pretty sure there's another Enron brewing
somewhere. [laughter]
Yeah, everything we do is user-submitted.
We have a blog called, "It Made My Day," which
-- if you've ever checked on Twitter.
If you've seen the tag 'IMMD' on Twitter -- that's
where it comes from, a blog called, "It Made
My Day," which is either about something really
nice that's happened to you, or something
really bad that's happened to somebody else,
that you witnessed, so.
It's just different forms of user-generated
content.
Q I follow that actually. I'm sorry.
Ben Huh: Go ahead.
Q Can I ask one more?
"It Made My Day" -- I actually thought that
was from the producers of FML, which I'll
leave that acronym there.
But was that a response to FML?
Ben Huh: That was absolutely response to FML.
The question was, Was IMMD inspired by FML?
Absolutely true. It's like the opposite of
FML. All right?
So in most cases, the opposite of whatever
we're doing tends to be also true, and also
appeals to an audience.
And that's the thing about this fragmented
audience is that, if we're doing one thing,
we might as well go do the opposite as well,
so.
Yeah. There's a question back there, I think.
Q [inaudible]
Ben Huh: I'll just repeat the question.
How do we prevent abuse?
Everything that's submitted to our system
is seen by a paid moderator.
So what we do is, we have somebody who screens
all the photos as they come in, for 'terms
of service' violations.
It's really expensive to do, and it's really
laborious, but I feel it has a really positive
effect on the community.
Like I can't imagine somebody at YouTube doing
this, because then, they'd be like, just bored
out of their minds of all the cat videos that
come in.
But you know, that's what we do, and it's
just part of our culture to actually pay for
that service to do it.
But yeah, that's how we prevent abuse.
>> Do we have any other questions from the
other offices, Tim? No.
>> Yeah, we do actually. Question from Ann
Arbor.
>> Go ahead, Ann Arbor.
Q Oh, great, thanks.
Are you planning on expanding your merchandise
at all, for I Can Has Cheezburger?
Ben Huh: I'm sorry, could?
Are we planning on expanding merchandise?
Yes, we actually are.
Thank you for that segway; I owe you five
dollars. [laughter]
In November, we plan on launching an "Internet
Mean T-shirt A Day" program.
So just like shirt.woot, but with Internet
culture products.
So like, it's a shirt.
Like, I wish I was wearing one.
It's like, I've got a red shirt.
It's got like Long Cat on one, and it's got
like the big towers, like Sears Tower, or
like all those things -- buildings.
And then, it'll have their feet, like number
of feet -- 2000 feet or whatever.
And then, the long cat is like over 9,000
feet.
You know, stuff like that.
Just Internet sub-humor stuff like that.
We want to just do one T-shirt a day to make
it limited.
And I think it would be a lot of fun, so.
Yeah. You had a question.
Q [inaudible]
Ben Huh: Yeah, how long can we afford to pay
for human moderation?
That's a very good question.
I think the answer is, "Until we can't."
And I really don't know.
And this is kind of the philosophy of running
a company '30 days at a time' is that, you
know, we're small enough where we can be very
nimble.
And if we feel that the expenses are going
out of line, we'll have to figure out an answer,
but until we have to do that, we're going
to concentrate on what we do best, which is
launch new sites.
I'm sure somebody, somewhere in my office,
is going to be screaming going, "Oh, my God!
We spent that much on moderation?"
And we'll say, "Okay, let's take a look, and
see how much value that is to us."
But we don't have any plans to phase it out.
I think that's -- in fact, I think we only
have plans to increase it to 24-hours coverage.
Because right now, they sit in a queue, unless
there's a moderator on staff.
So there's three shifts of people who look
at this stuff every day.
So we try to cover as much of the time clock
as possible.
And we want to expand that.
Yes.
Q [inaudible]
Ben Huh: Where are our visitors coming from?
Yeah, we're about 65 percent United States
and 35 percent international.
It tends to do with the fact that we have
an English-language blog, so unless you understand
kind of western culture and know English well
enough.
Because, you have to know English to understand
when it's misspelled. [laughter]
And it's weird, because you have to know English
well enough to understand when things are
really misspelled correctly, right? [laughter]
So like Kara Swisher, who's a very famous
blogger and reporter for the Wall Street Journal
-- loves lolcats -- she posts lolcats on
our blog.
So one of the things that we countered was,
people would have very interesting misconceived
notions about why people misspell things.
So one lady came up to me and said, "You know,
I like your lolcats, but I hate the fact that
you assume that my cats can't spell." [laughter]
And my response was, "It's not that they can't
spell, it's that they choose not to spell
like we do, because they're better than us."
And she's like, "Oh." [laughter]
I mean, she had a very, you know, new-found
respect for her cat after that.
So like Paul Krugman, the Nobel Prize winner
of Economist, used a lolcat on his blog.
So these are people who are very intelligent,
and this is what I tell people, it's like,
"No, they're not misspelling because they
don't know how to spell English."
"No, it is not a form of ebonics," which happened
by the way.
Somebody called the NAACP and said, "Lol cats
are racist." [laughter]
Yeah, so. It's not that.
It's actually people who are very smart, who
tend to play with language, and that's how
they evolve things.
So, yeah. Go ahead.
Q [inaudible]
Ben Huh: That's a very good question.
Do we have plans to expand internationally?
There were some people who were trying to
translate lolcats to Spanish.
And I don't know if that worked, because it
tends to be cultural.
Because we focus things at small cultures
within a large group.
It tends to be very -- it's not just a translation
that works.
It has to match that culture.
Lol cats are somewhat known in Japan, but
they're not wildly popular in a culture where
they love cats, right?
There's something interesting about that phenomenon.
Why isn't it as popular?
They actually have a relatively good grasp
of English.
They're taught in school. Why not?
It's just something that I haven't been able
to figure out yet.
Yeah.
Q So, I'm interested in your perspective on
search.
How does one exactly search for a cute picture
with misspellings that might not be linked
off anywhere on the Internet?
A Yeah, so, that's a very good question.
I think it's very relevant here.
We tend to give it a specific type of nomenclature,
or we tend to take a phrase that is used regularly
in our culture.
So for example, "There I Fixed It."
What would you search for?
Pictures of horrible fix-up jobs?
I mean, that's really long.
I mean, that's like not something that people
think about.
But if you give it a name like "There I Fixed
It," which is a phrase that we would be familiar
with in everyday life, right?
Or "It Made My Day," right?
That's how people search.
They look for the name of the blog.
And I was talking to Matt Cutts about this
-- your chief spam cop guy.
And one of the things I think he found fascinating
was that, we don't really care about SCO.
Like, we own the term 'lolcat'.
We own the term 'cheeseburger' actually. [laughter]
Cheeseburger ranks number two for the search
for the word 'funny.'
FAIL blog ranks number three for the word
funny, right?
We don't do SCO, because organically, we have
no idea what people are going to call us.
So we just try to rank for the term that is
the name of the site, which is actually relatively
easy to do -- thank you, Google.
Like, before you guys were around, I Can Has
Cheezburger would never have taken off, right?
Before search was actually this effective,
no one was going to search for "I can what?"
No one knew our name, yet people found us.
And that's through the power of search.
Like, if you type in anything remotely close
to I Can Has Cheezburger, like remotely close
-- "we has a cheeseburger" -- you end up
on I Can Has Cheezburger. [laughter]
So, thank you. Long-winded way of saying,
"Thank you for that."
So by the way, we have books for Graph Jam,
FAIL blog, and I Can Has Cheezburger, if you
want to buy them.
There's also Happy Cats -- the cat that spawned
it all -- with a little stuffed animal version
of that cat.
So, MJ's here to take your order if you'd
like them.
But yeah, that's pretty much all I have to
say.
>> Great. Thank you very much.
>> [Clapping]